I'm ready to be a dad Adam Levine and
his wife be aati Prinsloo are expecting
their first child later this year ET
spoke with the singer on thursday at the
voices karaoke for charity event where
he opened up about becoming a father how
are you prepping for baby girl oh man
I'm prepping happen yeah I'm ready to be
a dad you ready yeah you'll be a great
dad I think so I was kind of we were
born to be a parent that's what we're
here for really all the other is great
but it's not what we're here for you
know have any of your fellow coaches
giving you any advice no you know I
think we've just been pretty everyone
loves you know when you weave in the
scenario is when you are doing this for
the first time everybody loves to tell
you what you should be doing so we kind
of like tune a lot of it out and we're
like we're just gonna do how we do it
and not listening to too much of it but
it's good to get advice as well
sometimes one person who thinks adam has
the whole fatherhood thing already down
his fellow voice coach Pharrell I think
it's gonna be a great dad he's
competitive and and like it's in it you
know he's in he's a really engaged type
of person so I think he's gonna be
really engaged with his son or daughter